les syndicats qui bloquent le pays le
gouvernement qui contre attaque
les grèves sont un rapport de force et
au milieu de cette bataille il y à un
facteur déterminant c'est vous ce qu'on
appelle l'opinion publique l'appui de
l'opinion publique et eu un argument ou
du moins une condition nécessaire mais
pas suffisante pour faire reculer un
gouvernement c'est nécessaire parce que
le gouvernement ne reculera jamais s'il
sent pas qu'il ya une ferveur populaire
contre son projet on n'est pas dans un
camp du bien contre un quand du mal et
chacun choisirait son camp quand une
grève dure l'opinion peut se retourner à
la fois contre les grévistes
sur le tableau maintenant ça suffit on
nous empêche de travailler nous
empêchent de circuler et contre les
gouvernants qui passe parce qu'ils
auraient aimé une réforme trop dur ou
mal géré la chose des draps
obtenir l'appui de l'opinion publique ce
n'est pas une science exacte mais il ya
tout de même des ingrédients à mettre en
place
le premier de ces ingrédients c'est la
cause soutenue par les grévistes
une bonne cause en général ce sont des
gens vers lesquels on éprouve de la
sympathie alors les grèves des soignants
des infirmiers des agriculteurs ou des
mouvements sociaux de quoi des
agriculteurs en général suscitent
beaucoup de sympathie à linverse le
souvenir d'une grève qui elle n'était
pas du tout du tout soutenu c'est celle
qu'elle a battu un record celle des
personnels navigants d'air france juste
avant la coupe du monde de 98 le second
ingrédient c'est la cote de popularité
du gouvernement
plus celle-ci est basse et plus les
grévistes auront l'appui de la
population en l'occurrence la cote de
popularité des manuels macron est très
basse alors que plus de la moitié des
français disent lui faire confiance
après son élection
ils sont désormais un peu plus d'un
quart deux ans plus tard on est dans un
climat où le président de la république
et même des macros certes à récupérer
quelques plumes par rapport au creux de
la crise des gilet jaune
enfin il reste rejetée par près des deux
tiers des français dont certains se
disent après tout si des gens peuvent
aller dans la rue exprimer mon
ressentiment à l'égard de ce qu boire
bien finalement je trouve ça plutôt
sympathique
le troisième ingrédient c'est qu'il faut
une cause où chacun se sent concerné par
exemple le sujet de la retraite des
cheminots ne concerne qu'une minorité de
français alors qu'une réforme des
retraites concerne l plus de la majorité
de la population
ensuite elle les contours de la réforme
sont suffisamment un liste un peu chacun
ce livre mais je suis concerné aussi de
fait cette réforme concerne vraiment
beaucoup d'aspects notamment la question
de l'accumulation de points et d'un
système avec la valeur d'un point qui
peuvent faire que beaucoup de français
se sont enchaînés donc tout le monde un
jour ou l'autre basculera de la période
d'activité qu'il soit au chômage ou en
emploi à d'inactivité totale
c'est-à-dire la retraite donc ça
concerne tournée c'est pour ça que tout
le monde se sent concerné par cette
réforme dont on connaît peu de choses
qui inquiète beaucoup et était assez
intéressant de voir un récent sondage
qui disait qu à la fois presque 60% des
français soutenaient ou avait de la
sympathie pour les grévistes
et qu'en même temps il pensait que le
gouvernement ne devait pas renoncer à sa
réforme et l est jusqu où il ya aussi
beaucoup d'ambiguïtés ce qui fait qu'une
bataille d'opinion avant la vraie
bataille ne signifie pas une bataille
gagnée une fois ces ingrédients mis en
place il faut pour les deux camps les
grévistes et le gouvernement activer
certains levier pour faire bouger les
positions
le principal levier qui est dans la main
des syndicats et les agents qui se
mettraient en grève notamment qui
paralysait les transports
c'est à dire on se moque vous seul truc
c'est de démontrer c'est de montrer que
le gouvernement d'une dans une stratégie
d'opposition systématique et reste
absolument sourd à toutes les
revendications
c'est exactement ce que fait la cgt si
vous prenez depuis deux mois et même
plus qui on remonte au début de la
concertation qui date de 2010 est à
chaque fois que communiqué que la
société sur un communiqué sur la réforme
des retraites
après avoir été reçu par une autre
philippe ou après avoir été reçus par
jean paul delevoye le haut commissaire à
la réforme des retraites c'est toujours
le gouvernement reste sourd à nos
propositions et pour le gouvernement
tout l'enjeu est de se montrer à
l'écouté il doit montrer que ce
mouvement de grève n'ont pas à être
impopulaire mais il n'est pas légitime
et c'est pour ça qu'on entend à ce club
depuis quelques jours sur une grève de
nantis ce sont ces pour préserver des
inégalités c'est
les régimes spéciaux qui veulent
conserver leur petit privilège
d'ingrédients à la main du gouvernement
ça peut être mais c'est toujours assez
dangereux de stigmatiser les grévistes
de jouer l'opinion contre les grévistes
mais à plusieurs reprises ça plutôt
échoué ça peut être de d'évoluer de
bouger de montrer qu ils entendent ça
peut être aussi bien sûr d'expliquer le
bien fondé de la réforme parce que si on
a aujourd'hui 60 % des gens qui
soutiennent qu'ils soutiennent les
grévistes probablement parmi eux il ya
des gens qui seraient assez accessible
aux grands principes de la réforme qui
après tout a vu un moment suscité
l'intérêt l'opinion publique de toute
façon la stratégie du gouvernement c'est
de laisser pourrir le truc tout en
montrant qu'il est ouvert la discussion
il doit philippe disant ma porte elle
est ouverte tous m'ont peut discuter il
a reçu les syndicats et le patronat
pendant deux jours à matignon pour
écouter ce qu'ils avaient à dire comme
s'il ne savait pas faut pas être dupe 1
via les propositions ou les
contre-propositions des organisations
syndicales les agresseurs patronale le
premier nice qui concerte sur la
question depuis deux ans les connaît par
coeur mais pour autant avoir l'appui de
la population ne fait pas forcément
gagné un combat mais après plus les
désagréments dur plus les blocages dur -
la graine au populaire il ya toujours
une espèce un moment un point
d'inflexion à un moment où on voit que
la grève devient plus impopulaire
qu'elle n'est pas qu'elle n'est
populaire soutien plus large dans
l'opinion veut pas dire forcément plus
grande mobilisation et dans la durée ça
tient à d'autres ingrédients qui sont la
capacité de mobilisation
la situation personnelle des
des agents amenés à faire grève la
capacité aussi financière à tenir ou pas
une grève dans la durée puis ça dépend
bien entendu dans la posture des
gouvernants est ce qu'ils vont répliquer
l'attitude d'alain juppé en 1995 et la
dernière fois qu'un mouvement de grève a
eu raison d'une mesure d'état
c'était il ya plus de 13 ans avec le cpe
porté par dominique de villepin
donc là ça avait été une condition
nécessaire et suffisante pour pouvoir
faire reculer le gouvernement
mais notez que c'était en 2006 c'était
il ya treize ans et vous n'avez pas
depuis
u11 exécutif qui a reculé face à la rue
lorsque g ces projets étaient contestées
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout vous pouvez retrouver
toutes nos vidéos décrypteurs ici et
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à notre
chaîne